it's not easy to to get this across what
what does it mean ecstatic truth
and what constitutes just mere fact
which is the the truth of accountants
even though one has to
we shouldn't dismiss the power effects
because
as one of the lessons says facts create
norms and they create norms including
ethical norms when you see for example
footage shot in concentration camps
right after they were liberated is
it is fact fact fact and nothing but
that and it has
such an immense power that it creates
norms of
moral behavior so we should not
dismiss that but it's it's not the end
of it it's not
it's not what can be reached in cinema
there is a
there are deeper strata of truth and you
have to be inventive and you have to
fabricate
and you have to stylize and and you have
to
to to catch and try to find this elusive
magic of images and if we don't have
these images
if we don't develop an adequate language
of images an adequate grammar of images
our civilization will be sort
of maybe even die out like the dinosaurs
i have the feeling that we must develop
adequate
images and they are limping behind they
are lagging behind there have been such
dramatic evolutions in the last
past decades and when you look at
on a television or at much of what
hollywood does
there is something very unsatisfying and
there is a deep
gap between what is us and what these
images are
and so that's where we have to we have
to look out for that